[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here so you're doing
your exercises you're paying attention
to your food intake but the weight just
won't budge you're wondering what on
earth am I doing wrong
well what should this video through as I
will be sharing with you ten common
reasons why you're not losing weight
number one your expectations are
unrealistic I've been receiving too many
comments asking me how can I lose 10
kilos in a month or even a week my
simple answer is look it did not take
you one month to put on 10 kilos it
probably took you over several months or
even years for the weight to slowly
creep on hence it will take your time to
lose weight the safe and sustainable
weight loss is between 1 to 2 pounds a
week so don't set yourself unrealistic
expectations because then you're only
setting yourself up for failure you get
frustrated when you don't see results as
quickly as you hope to if you have lost
some weight and you feel good about
yourself but the skill doesn't seem to
want to budge any further then perhaps
it is time for you to learn to accept
and love your body the way it is because
at some point your weight will reach a
healthy set mark and it won't budge any
further to try to go beyond that will be
unhealthy so set yourself realistic and
achievable goals the second reason is
you are losing without realizing it it
is very important for us to understand
that our weight fluctuates every single
day it can fluctuate up to 5 pounds in a
day so if you were to measure yourself
in the morning afternoon and in the
evening chances are you will have 3
different measurements so this is due to
the amount of water in the body so
throughout the day our body will hold on
to the fluids from food and also drinks
hence that is why you tend to feel
lighter in the morning and heavier
towards the evening your weight loss
progress should not just be measured by
the number on the scale this is in fact
the least most accurate way to measure
your weight loss progress because we
want to be losing body fat not just
weight we can be gaining muscles and
losing weight at the same time this is
especially common if you just started
exercising so instead of stepping on the
scale and allowing a VAT
number two determine how well you're
doing take your body measurements and
see how well your clothes are fitting
you if your clothes are fitting you
better but the skill just one badge well
that just means that you are losing body
fat by you're putting on muscles which
is a great thing and you should not be
worried about it next you're bingeing
unhealthy food I'm sure you have seen
this phrase guilt-free treats every so
often nowadays a lot of us tend to have
the mindset that just because a food is
categorized as healthy that gives us the
permission to eat as much as we want
because hey it's good for you and it
will do you no harm but what you might
feel to realize is that one slice of
healthy raw cake might have the same
amount of calories as a slice of
chocolate cake so just because something
is healthy that doesn't mean that you
can help yourself to several servings
and fool yourself into thinking that it
will not affect your weight loss
progress it is important to know that
even if something is really healthy the
calories still count so treat yourself
in moderation you've been doing the same
thing over and over again so if you have
been on the same routine and losing
weight for many months and you have hit
a plateau then perhaps you just need to
take a break okay brick for your workout
a break from your diet and just try
something completely different sleep
more eat more than you're used to try
new activities and just take it easy the
more stressed out you are about losing
weight and the harder it is for you to
progress so instead of just focusing on
the end goal it is very important for
you to enjoy the entire journey the next
reason is you're not drinking enough
water ask yourself are you drinking
between 2.5 to 3 liters of water every
single day drinking enough water is so
easy to forget but it is crucial to your
weight loss success if your body is
dehydrated if your workout and your
progress will suffer oftentimes we think
we're hungry but we're really just
thirsty so the next time you feel hungry
instead of grabbing snacks and start
munching drink water first and ask
yourself if you're truly hungry or just
dehydrated drinking water before a meal
can also make you feel fuller as
result you will eat less the next point
you're drinking your calories are you
one of those people who enjoy fruit
juices soda drinks fancy coffee or even
alcohol liquid calories in just about
any form of sneaky calories those drinks
are loaded with calories and some may
even contain more calories than a proper
meal just by eliminating liquid calories
you can save up to 500 calories in a day
and you will see a huge difference to
your weight loss progress next you're
probably not lifting weights are you a
cardio bunny
if so chances are you look skinny fat
with no muscle tone it is time to lift
some weights okay weight lifting can
help to build and preserve a muscle mass
and prevent metabolic slowdown when you
only do cardio you've been fat only
during the workout and it stops shortly
after the workout now if you include
strength training your body continues to
burn fat even after the workout while at
rest and this is also known as the after
burn effect which can speed up weight
loss stress are you overwhelmed are you
constantly on the go do you struggle to
even breathe properly or do you have
issues that you have to deal with
whatever reason stress can be the
underlying cause of your witness
struggle especially weight around the
belly that's because of the hormone
called cortisol which makes your body
hold on to fat so if you're someone who
is very disciplined in your workout and
food intake but you struggle to lose
belly fat ask yourself what is your
stress level like if it means taking 10
minutes in the evening to wind down I
would recommend you to do that because
it can make a huge difference to your
weight loss progress what I like to do
is light up scented candles and reflect
on the positive things in my day it
helps me to sleep better and I wake up
feeling more energized thus another
stress relates a problem is lack of
sleep when you do not get enough rest
your hormones go crazy boosting the
levels of ghrelin which increases your
appetite you're basically putting your
body into carb and fat survival mode
your metabolism slows down because it's
trying to maintain its resources but at
the same time your body wants more food
that is when the late night snacking
starts to take over just to keep you
awake and finally you're too focused on
dieting if there is one thing you can do
right now is ditch the word dieting when
we think of dieting it is often
associated to restriction short-term and
unsustainable regimes most people who
have the mindset of dieting tend to gain
more weight over time so ditch dieting
and change that to healthy eating focus
on nourishing your body with good food
instead of depriving it and weight loss
will happen as a natural side effect
because primarily our goal is to be
fitter healthier and live a more
fulfilled life so I hope that this video
will help you to take another look at
your fitness journey ok instead of just
being obsessed over the number on the
skill or being so obsessed over our
goals it is very important to enjoy the
entire journey so be sure to give this
video a thumb up share with your friends
and subscribe to my youtube channel for
a lot more fitness tips nutritional tips
recipes workout videos and don't forget
to turn on your notification button so
that you will get notified every time I
upload a new video all the best